hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
with destiny - upon us I thought we
should go back in time and refresh our
memories of the first destiny title and
all those DLC and the expansions so sit
back grab the popcorn and let's relive
three years of grind let's start off
with the magic golf ball in the sky it
may look ridiculous but it's the most
important element in destiny and the
sequel this is the traveller it has the
ability to terraform planets changing
the atmosphere the temperature the
ecology basically everything that makes
a planet habitable just like our home
here on earth as the 21st century came
to a close
humanity tracks down the traveller on
Mars and made contact it ended up being
a great decision as it gave us a wealth
of knowledge to create technology only
possible in science fiction films so
what did mankind do with all the newly
acquired information off we went to
check out every corner of our solar
system settling on many planets such as
Venus and a few moons - destiny tells us
this is the Golden Age of humanity as
it's always the case nothing lasts
forever and the Golden Age collapsed the
traveler who was seen as a God by many
of mankind was being pursued by an
unknown force only referenced as the
darkness darkness a real threat it
became apparent that the traveler
continually moved on after terraforming
planets in a way to keep the darkness at
bay mankind in part were prepared for
the coming war through the creation of
weapons of mass destruction these
included some awesome weapons like the
Gjallarhorn a rocket with tracking solar
shells this was such a great weapon
during destined a year one all the
weapons included the entire EXO race who
were created in the image of humanity
but built for combat purposes same to
for the six war Minds who were
artificial intelligence strategic
warfare entities built for the same
purpose-- protect humanity fighting a
losing battle where almost all of
humanity was obliterated the traveler
sacrificed itself to save mankind with
its dying breath of life that
travela created ghosts these cute little
buggers were tasked with finding great
warriors and key personnel who could
harness the light a mythical power that
traveller possesses these risen dead
became known as the guardians that's
where the game begins as our ghost
locates our dead corpse and resurrects
us our ghost acts as a companion a scout
a tour guide a computer hacker a
librarian and best of all a torch in
those dark corridors
he's like a Swiss Army knife of Awesome
the ghost and all subsequent powers we
received as Guardians are powered by the
travelers light so you can see why the
golf ball in the sky is so important to
the story essentially destiny is an
age-old story of light two versus dark
good versus evil anyway once awake we
quickly find a way to repair our first
ship we travel to the last city on earth
which was built around the final resting
place of the traveler welcome to the
last safe city on earth the only place
the traveler can still protect
it took centuries to build now we're
counting every day it stands
and this tower is where the Guardians
live here we meet the three Guardians
who make up the Vanguard Zavala
Kate and I chorus commander Zavala is
arguably the overall leader of the group
with a strong military background
he's a very matter-of-fact and not to be
joked with he cayde-6 on the other hand
is always joking he brings off-the-wall
suggestions to the table and thinks
outside the box at Quora if you tell me
this is a Brandel joke well it kills me
to say it but I would be really
impressed impressing you Cade is the
easiest thing I'll do all day finally I
Cora Rae is the scholar of the Vanguard
with a wealth of knowledge making her
the perfect foil to Kate's antics
coincidentally the Vanguard also
represents all forms of modern-day
humanity human EXO and awoken and all
three character class options we have to
Titan hunter and warlock wonderful life
by the way hunter for life amongst other
important personalities we meet the
speaker is the key character because of
his connection to the traveller until it
wakes and finds its voice I am the one
who speaks for the trouble
our Guardian is convinced to join the
cause and is subsequently sent on
numerous missions around the solar
system join your ghost will guide you I
only hope you chose wisely I did I'm
sure we're in this together
we first encountered the Fallen on earth
[Applause]
they're a ragtag group of pirate
mercenaries fill pop up that's almost
every location in the game we take down
septics prime an overgrown servitor who
is our first real challenge as a
guardian our travels then take us to
Earth's moon where we find the hive an
undead army with supernatural abilities
as luck would have it we perfectly time
our fact-finding mission and discover
the hive are preparing to invade earth
and attack the last city so of course
action must be taken after battling our
way through to the ritual chamber here
it is the darkest of all the highest
chambers we discovered the hive had a
shard of the traveler and was stripping
the light from it thus taking life force
from the big golf ball in the sky keep
in mind I'm part of the lightest two
Guardians we need that light to keep our
ridiculous abilities
they were using it against the traveler
devouring its light
we've read it if you were paying
attention during the opening few hours
of the campaign a mysterious female XO
is tracking our Guardian at this point
she tells us to go to Venus and as the
good lapdogs we are we do exactly what a
stranger tells us to reaches here on
Venus our guardian locates a conflict
which belongs to the next race of super
buddies we'll be taking down the vex
these guys are mechanized and
militarized race of beings that all
share a single consciousness they have
the sole purpose of spreading across the
galaxy making attempts to communicate
with them futile the conflict is their
way to transport across galaxies in a
moment it's basically a portal or a time
gate once we've dispatched this vex
scouting party the stranger turns up to
give us some useful information who are
you why are you watching us I don't even
have time to explain why I don't have
time to explain she does speak in
riddles but credit to her she lets us
know about the black garden find the
black garden rip out its heart
only then will travel to begin to heal
to get to that black garden our guardian
is first sent to the reef to speak to
the queen of the awoken where is all
this come from
every ship that could escape fled earth
during the collapse they made it this
far I guess they died up here it's a
graveyard
the awoken are a tricky race to decipher
they began as normal everyday humans who
attempted to outrun the darkness the
darkness caught up to the convoy and
massacred the majority of the fleet but
remarkably some of the populace managed
to survive how did the awoken survived
no one knows
sadly something changed in them and they
were no longer human and are described
as the awoken out their wavering between
the light and the dark
their motivations and loyalties are
unknown but the leadership system is
based on monarchy I am a guardian from
Earth we're searching for the black
garden do you know where it is
everyone knows where it is the awoken
eventually agreed to help us find a
passage to the black garden but with an
annoying caveat we'll make you a key
how's that all we need is the head of a
VEX gate Lord yeah we why do you want a
vex head oh we don't and I doubt we'll
get one either so once again we go on an
adventure to bring back the goods back
on Venus our Guardians systematically
wrecks the vex and retrieves the head of
a gate Lord without breaking a sweat
once it's taken to the awoken we find
that the gate Lords head has a trinket
inside which will allow us passage to
the black garden we gift it in sympathy
for their traveler Mars 84 north 32 East
looks like we're going to Mars but
before we can go the Queen tells us that
we owe her a favor should the awoken
never need an ally I will call on you
and expect you to answer
looks like we'll be coming back in the
dlc anyway after Mars we go here on the
red planet we meet the Cabal who are the
final race encountered in destiny one
story and these guys will also play the
primary enemy in destiny to the cabal's
heritage is pretty cool they're
essentially a race of brick [ __ ]
war machine rhinos who are kicked out of
their own empire when going into war the
only way to be taken back is to be
victorious in battle this ultimately
makes the Cabal completely focused in
every fight as they can't ever retreat
without giving up their life hardcore
but brilliant before we can enter the
black garden we need to charge the gate
Lords eye by hacking of x-pyr protected
by the Cabal sounds difficult but we're
a badass Guardian so this was but a bump
in the road now back to the black garden
the transfer gate to the black garden is
fortified by the vest approaching the
seemingly redundant structure brings it
to life and in an instant we travel
across space and time after battling
through to the heart of the black garden
our guardian is able to trick the
Conflux into thinking they are a gate
Lord and now it's time for the final
battle so think you can kill Oh God
don't think I have a choice
it's a bit of a tough fight but we
fulfill our destiny so you're a dipper
and destroy the house of the butt guard
and vanquish in the darkness
[Music]
to end the story the speaker gives a
rousing speech about how great guardians
are before the stranger gives us her
rifle which is absolutely trash but it's
a nice sentiment all the same
I'll let the stranger have the last say
in this story our fight is far from over
[Music]
well that was bloody anticlimactic in
destiny's first expansion we focus on
the hive and Eris morn a morally grey
individual who never feels trustworthy
even though she used to be a guardian
she has was destroyed the sword of crota
and the sworn Prince's as well as a
whole bunch of hive generals the hive
are revealed to be awakening the soul of
crota a god-like being who is bad news
for Humanity he will turn his eyes to
earth we banish crotas soul and
everything is great again the hive
managed to release proto regardless but
during the raid we eventually kill crota
once and for all
the next expansion House of wolves has
the queen of the awoken calling in that
favor we owe them our Guardian is tasked
with taking down the hall and who have
risen up against the awoken we
successfully take down the house of
wolves and their kelp scholars scroll us
he's pulling the entire house of waltz
through time scholars was attempting to
use vex technology to further his goals
but now he's a prisoner of the awoken
and a prison of elders short of the
sweet
remember when we killed that hive
godlike being crota well his dad's Oryx
has found out about it and has arrived
to wipe us all out
let's see things from his point of view
we stopped every hive attempt to invade
earth and killed his toddler crota it's
only right that he's a bit mint anyway
the awoken are the first to confront the
hive gods and our wiped out in one swoop
of oryxes sword
all of woken forces are killed instantly
which includes the Queen and her
annoying brother we don't actually see
them die on camera so maybe they're
still around somewhere
Oryx wields the power of the darkness
and is building an army of taken these
are former hive fallen vex and cabal
that have been corrupted by the darkness
and now obey is every whim
back in the last city the Vanguard are
attempting to understand the Hawkins
decision to fight a far superior force
when Eris walks in they are taken Eris
get your rock off my map it hasn't
spoken since crota fell it speaks now
because Oryx has arrived
Kasich's comes up with a plan to get a
guardian on Oryx his base of operations
called the dread-nots using a stealth
drive and Eris morn ship which smells a
bit like hive isn't this err small ship
is it Kate and ship right amanda sent an
illegal scouting trip to the dread-nots
an unsanctioned art using modified
stealth tech to infiltrate a dreadnought
above Saturn's rings so we can knock out
its weapons create a transman zone
the cavalry how about test life
the stealth drive bricks on the journey
and we are killed
the end
now we jump off just in time but eres
Mon [ __ ] won't be coming home anytime
soon next our guardian discovers the
gateway to Oryx can only be opened by
ascendant time so we are forced to
detour and rub ourselves on crotas dead
bits to mimic the ascendant hive I'm
sure it's more technical than that but
ultimately it's just standing on the
dead things lovely
now that our Guardian can pass through
the rupture we face Oryx and beat the
[ __ ] out of a grieving father like the
true heroes we are
an added cinematic shows how the awoken
Queen and Eris morn were working
together and manipulating us for their
own means this there is six a strange
object from the remnants of oryxes sword
but we know no more we are literally
just left we have no idea what happens
next before his death though Oryx fully
embraces the darkness to allow for
another in-game rate but once we killed
him in his own throne room no less then
he's dead for real this time
and the hive war is stopped before it
has a chance to start the final
expansion of destiny one season looking
at the history of the iron Lords who
we've been fighting for in a monthly
event called iron banana
sorry iron banner without really knowing
why the Fallen have discovered a strange
nanotechnology which is accelerating
their combat abilities and making their
race essentially super-powered due to
the technological German the first super
weapon is septics Prime the first boss
we ever fought in year 1 destiny who is
now at a perfected status alongside the
last iron lord saladin we launched a war
on the house of the Fallen Devils which
finally reveals the history of those
iron Lords essentially the iron Lords
were a group of guardians who protected
humanity during the Golden Age one of
their key responsibilities was to bring
down guardians who had become a little
drunk on power and became tyrannical
rulers known as war logs once these were
taken care of
the iron Lords discovered sievert which
was created by mankind a long time ago
nanotechnology with the ability to
consume materials in order to assist in
the colonization of planets the nanotech
may have been created to help humanity
inhabit planets but the issue of
destroying planets could not be ignored
and the project was terminated if you've
played horizon zero dawn it's pretty
much the same principle as the zero dawn
project the iron Lords attempted to once
again use Sivir to assist humanity's
Renaissance at this point Rasputin one
of the war Minds created in the Golden
Age reactivated sensed a threat and used
Sivir to protect itself a long story
short the iron Lords fought their way
out of the facility with a touching
moment occurring when y'all
sacrificed herself to lock stiva away
forever
[Music]
with only two iron logs surviving Lord
Saladin calls it a day and closes the
door of the iron temple but now in the
presence the temple is open once again
over the course of the narrative we
track down the Seaver replication room
and find the dead iron Lords who have
now been infused with Siva what's
happening
boss into battle our Guardians defeat a
trio of former iron Lords including
Yalda
our final action is to destroy the stiva
plant narrowly escaping more explosions
than an 80s action film
[Music]
with Siva destroyed we can now take one
final trip to the ioan temple taking
with us a piece of iron Lord memorabilia
y'all does hell no less maybe we should
give this to Saladin we found this near
it thank you
she would be honored as a reward we are
given a flaming exotic sword which is
far better than the [ __ ] even we were
given by the stranger a couple years
earlier in our crowning moment we are
now officially an iron Lords take your
place as an iron Lord
so there you go three years of destiny
in super fast time now we are ready for
destiny two and another three years of
ground if you've picked up destiny -
then come join our discord and let's
play together details will be below I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]